I just try to do everything I can use
every tool that I have to entertain the
audience even as a little kid like I
used to steal lumber from uh junkyard
and then I'd ride down the hill as fast
as I could and hit the ramp and go over
garbage cans try to do that when I was a
little kid it didn't work it didn't work
I went down I went down the hill and the
bike you know was the pedal thing it
didn't have the reverse so I was going
really fast and then I went through it
and I split the wood in half and I went
smashing through the garbage cans and
then spent the next few days in the
hospital and you thought hey I want to
do this for a list this is what this is
what I want to do for a living